قالت الصين ان قوات بحريه وجويه روسيه
ستشارك في تدريبات مشتركه بين البلدين
ستجرى في الجزء الاوسط من بحر اليابان
وقالت بيجين ان هذه المناورات تهدف لتحسين
التفاعل الاستراتيجي بين الجيشين في
مواجهات التحديات الامنيه يتزامن ذلك مع
اعلان الجيشين الامريكي والياباني العمل
على خطه للدفاع عن تايوان ضد اي هجوم صيني
محتمل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما رسائل المناوره
الصينيه الروسيه في بحر اليابان وهل تمثل
تحولا في استراتيجيه بيجين في بحر جنوب
الصين من خلال تشكيل تحالف هجومي مع روسيا
وما مدى جديه ذلك ماذا تقول خطه واشنطن
بشان اي صراع صيني حول تايوان ولماذا تفضل
طوكيو الدعم اللوجستي على الانخراط
المباشر في اي مواجهه محتمله ما مستقبل
الامن في منطقه المحيط الهادئ في ضوء تنام
التوتر وازدحام مياهه بالحضور العسكري وهل
تساهم عوده الاتصالات بين واشنطن في نزع
فتيله
[موسيقى]
محيط اضحى مثالا يضرب في الازدحام العسكري
ففي اطرافه جيوش تجوب ارجاءه ومناورات
عسكريه تقطع هدوءه بمؤشرات للتوتر لا
تخطئها العين انه المحيط الهادئ وفي القلب
منه قنبله موقوته هي تايوان التي عليها
يدور توتر امريكي صيني يرتفع منسوبه بين
حين واخر الصين سوقت لتدريباتها العسكريه
المشتركه مع روسيا بالقول انها ستركز بشان
الحفاظ على امن الممرات البحريه
الاستراتيجيه مضيفه انها ترمي الى التعزيز
القدره على الحفاظ على السلام والاستقرار
الاقليميين بشكل مشترك تحركات لا يغفل
عنها الجيش الامريكي الذي اكد انه يعمل
منذ اكثر من عام مع نظيرها الياباني على
خطه للدفاع عن تايوان في حال حصول هجوم
صيني لكن من دون ان يشارك الجيش الياباني
عسك
تقول تقارير ان الولايات المتحده شجعت
اليابان على دور عسكري اوسع غير ان طوكيو
التي ابدت استعدادها لدعم الجيش الامريكي
بتوفير الوقود والامدادات الاخرى ترفض
اشراك جيشها عسكريا مع واشنطن
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيجين
رونج وان الاعلامي والكاتب الصحفي معنى من
نيويورك دانس مدير مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي السابق لشؤون الصين ومن عمان
ينضم الينا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكم جميعا
سنبدا معك
في الصين ما الرسائل ما الرساله
الصينيه الروسيه من وراء هذه المناورات في
هذا التوقيت
اهلا ومرحبا بكم هذه
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه هي من ضمن
اختها التعاون
والتدريبات يعني المتفق عليها سابقا يعني
وكذلك هذا هذه التدريبات
تحريفيه للحمايه الممرات
الاستراتيجيه البحريه وكذلك هو من اجل
التعزيز الاستقرار والسلام في هذا المنطقه
وكذلك من اجل مواجهات اي تحديدات تحديات
امنيه المحتمله في المستقبل
الولايات المتحده
الرسائل من وراء هذه التدريبات المشتركه
لماذا
المتحده قلقه من العسكره التي تحصل في
شمال شرق اسيا ليس فقط من قبل الصين
وروسيا ولكن ربما ايضا من كوريا الشماليه
هذه
الرحلات بالطائرات المقاتله التي يجرونها
منذ 2019 هي فيها اذا طيارون قادرون وكذلك
تحمل الكثير من الاسلحه وهذا يقلقنا يقلقه
حلفائنا وتدفعنا الى اتخاذ اجراءات دفاعيه
لكن يقول لنا السيد رونجوان الى هذه
المناورات تهدف لي
التدرب على الحفاظ على امن الممرات
المائيه الا يصب هذا في الهدف الامريكي
ايضا
الاعتقاقات على الاقل مع الهدف الامريكي
انا لا اعتقد انا استخدام طائرات مقاتله
تحميل قنابل نوويه هو ضمن القدرات
الدفاعيه لو كانت فقط تقوم بعمليه استطلاع
لا باس بذلك ولكن حين نستخدم هذه الاسلحه
هذا يعني اننا نقوم بمقاربه هجوميه وليس
هدف دفاعيه انا محلل عسكري منذ اربعين سنه
واعرف الفرق بين الدفاع والهجومي ساستمع
الى جوابك سيد قبل ان اذهب الى
فايز الدويري المحلي العسكري والاستراتيجي
من عمان
السيده نسويل يقول ان واشنطن قلق من
العسكره في المنطقه وان استخدام هذه
الاسلحه النوويه ربما لا يصب في مصلحه
الحفاظ على امن الممرات المائيه كيف ترد
اولا الصين لم تستخدم اي يعني اسلحه نوويه
فسين هناك هو دوله الوحيده النوويه التي
تتعهد بعدم
مبادره باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه وكذلك
عدم استخدام اسلحه النوويه ضد اي منطقه
يعني خاليه من الاسلحه النوويه ولا
تستخدمها الا عند تعرضها للهجوم النوويه
فلذلك ليس هنا اي قلق يعني
بما يخص باسلحه نوويه وكذلك الصين يعني كل
تدريبات العسكريه ومن اجل الدفاع عن
امنيه الوطني للصين
يعني تتماسك يعني السياسات الدفاعيه ذات
طبيعه الدفاعيه فلا تبادر الى هجوم الى اي
دوله الا عند تعرضها الى الهجوم من قبل
دوله اخرى
طيب لواء فايز الدويري ما اهميه هذه
المناورات وعلى ماذا يتم التدريب
يعني اولا هذه المناورات هي ليست وليده
اللحظه وليست المناوره الاولى هناك
مناورات اجرتها القوات الامريكيه مع جميع
الدول في المنطقه وفي اذا نظرنا الى السجل
هذه المناوره نجدها بالمئات خلال السنوات
والعقود الماضيه الان ما جرى ويجري على
الساحه الدوليه في اوكرانيا الاستداره
الامريكيه
الاستراتيجيه باتجاه بحر الصين الجنوبي
تعارض المصالح الصينيه الامريكيه في
المنطقه امريكا على سبيل المثال منذ مؤتمر
سنغافوره في 2010
طلب معظم وحضروا اكثر من 30 دوله طلبوا من
امريكا اعاده النظر في تواجدها من اجل
تحقيق التوازن الاستراتيجي
وزير الخارجي الامريكي
تحدث بانه سيتم اعاده التوازن الاستراتيجي
قبل 2020 الان المصالح الرئيسيه الامريكيه
تتلخص في منع هيمنه الصين على بحر الصين
الجنوبي لجمله اسباب اهمها موجودات النفط
سبعه مليار برميل 23 تريليون متر مكعب من
الغاز الممرات الرئيسيه واكثر واهم مرين
في العالم
ممرملكه وممر تايوان وبالتالي يوجد حشود
عسكريه
امريكيه ثلاث اضعاف حجم القوه الامريكيه
في اوروبا
يوجد مئه الف يوروبا يوجد
330,000 في جنوب شرق اسيا يوجد الاسطول
السابع العصب الرئيسي للبحريه الامريكيه
ومسؤوله
في المنطقه
نعم يوجد 330 الف جندي امريكي في جنوب شرق
اسيا بينما يوجد في اوروبا مئه الف جندي
امريكي يوجد ثلاث حاملات طائرات يوجد اكثر
من 300 قطعه بحريه يوجد و22 طائره شبحيه
استراتيجيه يوجد اكثر بستين طائره
[موسيقى]
ماذا تريد ان تحقق هذه المناورات
فرض التوازن الاستراتيجي والمحافظه على
مصالح الامريكيه في المنطقه والمحافظه على
حلفائها وبالتالي حتى اجرت مركز سي اس اي
اس الامريكي للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اجرى
لعب حرب اكثر من مره حول احتماليه غزو
صيني لتايوان وماذا على الامريكيين ان
يفعلوا وماذا على اليابان ان تفعل وما هي
مسار الحرب ونتائج الحرب وبالتالي هناك
اهتمام كبير جدا ولكن
تنامى هذا الاهتمام وتركز منذ عهد الرئيس
اوباما
اذا امام هذا الحشد الامريكي الكبير
المتواجد في المنطقه هذه المناورات تاتي
لتفرض التوازن ان كان الهدف الامريكي هو
الخوف من العسكره اليس هذا التواجد الكبير
هو ما يؤدي الى العسكره
فالوجود الامريكي العسكري كان مستقرا جدا
في المنطقه لدينا 27 الف جندي في كوريا
وذلك منذ سنوات في كوريا للحفاظ على
السلام في شبه الجزيره وهذا نجح لدينا عدد
من الجنود في اليابان ايضا العدد لم يرتفع
الصين هي التي قامت باجراءات عدائيه قامت
بعسكره بحر جنوب الصين ليس لدينا اي جزيره
في بحر جنوب الصين ولا ندعي اننا نسيطر
على اي منها ما يقلقناه هو
الممرات المفتوحه
والحره في مضيق تايوان ان 27% من السفن
التجاريه العالميه تمر بهذه المياه نحن
بحاجه الى حمايتها لان الصين وبطريقه
عدائيه
سيطرات على اجزاء كبيره من البحر وهذا
فعلا غير مقبول وسوف نستمر في التصدي لهذه
الادعاءات وذلك لما في مصلحه الاسره
الدوليه نحن لا نتصرف بعدائي نحن نتصرف
ونتحرك دفاعا عن النظام العالمي ان كانت
الولايات المتحده لا تتصرف بعدائيه سيد
دانس وايلدر كيف يفهم هذا الحث الامريكي
لليابان على الانخراط في اي خطه للدفاع عن
تايوان كما تكشف الخطط التي سربت في
واشنطن بوست
بكل صراحه
دعمت الصين الروس في اوكرانيا
رفضت ان تدينها
روسيا قامت باعمال عدائيه جدا في اوكرانيا
اليابان الاطلسي واسرى والفلبين وكوريا
الجنوبيه
كل هذه الاطراف قد اعربت عن قلق فعلي من
ان تقوم الصين او تحول القيام بنفس مقامته
او قامت به عفوا روسيا في اوكرانيا اذا
انشطه
اليابان
ودعموها لتايوان ودعم دول اخرى في المنطقه
تايوان صارت اهم الانواء اكبر لان الصين
صديقه حميمه لبوتين وروسيا قد اجتاحت
اوكرانيا بطريقه غير مقبوله ولا دعي لها
رونغه في بيجين يقول لنا سيد دانس ان
الازمه تمثل في ان الصين سيطرت على اجزاء
كبيره من البحر في منطقه اسيا وهذا غير
مقبول لان هذه ممرات ملاحه دوليه وان هذا
التواجد الامريكي في المنطقه
جزء كبير منه قديم
يعني هذا القديم هو اكبر يعني السبب
لتواتر في هذا المنطقه يعني قبل اكثر من
ست 70 سنه فعندما سين تحاول التوحيد
الكامل للبلاد فهو الاسطول السابعه يعني
وقف امام توحيد كامل للصين وسمى التداخل
القوات الامريكيه وحارب جيش التحرير
الشعبي الصيني في
الجزيره الكوريه وكل هذا هو اسباب يعني
حتى الان لم يتم التوحيد كامل للبلاد وهذا
هو اكبر سبب والان الصين تريد يعني مع
النحله العظيمه للامه الصينيه الصين تريد
اكمال هذه يعني مهمه التاريخيه لتوحيد
كامل للبلاد ولكن ما زال الولايات المتحده
تحاول يعني
عدم التحقيق يعني محاوله
في تحقيق سيدرون
ان الصين تريد توحيد كامل البلاد
الا يعطي هذا مشروعيه للمخاوف الامريكيه
على تايوان وامكانيه اجتياح تايوان
يعني يجب ان نعلم يعني لن توجد اي دوله
يعني حريص مثل الصين يعني تحرص على السلام
والاستقرار في هذه المنطقه لان اذا حدث اي
يعني مواجهات مباشره ستدمر يعني
تتدرب بها المواطنين في الصينيون في
الجانبين
فلذلك
الاكبر التواتر واكبر سبب التواتر هو بسبب
الانفصاليون في تايلان او الذين يسعون الى
الاستقلال وفصل تابعه عن الصين وكذلك
الدعم الامريكي لها
فلذلك يمكن نرى خلال عقود اذا تم يعني
الاتزام السارم بمبدا
هذه المنطقه هادئه ولا توجد اي توتر ولكن
اذا كان اي اقتراب او عدم التزام بمبدا
سنه واحده ومحاوله فصل تابعه عن فاصبح
هناك الازمه والتواتر فيعني يمكن ان نرى
اسباب الجذريه للتواتر في هذا المنتج
وكذلك
الخارجيه الامريكيه سيدرون
اكد ان الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بمبدا
الصين
الواحده اليس هذا كافيا بالنسبه للمسؤولين
الصينيين
ولكن يجب ان يكون الاقوال متطابقه مع
تحركات يعني الصين دائما اكدت يجب التطبيق
التوافقات التي تواصل اليها الرئيسين
الصين والامريكي الى ارض الواقع ولكن
التحركات
الامريكيه دائما تخالف التعهداتها امام
الصين
تقول عدم الدعم ولكن ما زال التبع الاسلحه
بشكل مستمر ايضا ويعني يعني دائما نجد
التنابتات بين الاقوال واكوارهم
كشف اذا عن خطه يعمل عليها الجيشين
الامريكي والياباني منذ سنه
لمواجهه سيناريو محتمل لغزو صيني لتايوان
مجرد وجود هذه الخطه بماذا يجب اعتقادك
يعني هناك تخوف امريكي من الاجراءات
الصينيه والاجراءات الصينيه قد اضعها في
بعدين البعد الاول وهو الهيمنه والسيطره
على بحر الصين الجنوبي وتحويل الى بحيره
صينيه وقد بدات الاجراءات الصينيه من خلال
بناء
الجزر الصناعيه والتي اصبحت تستخدم كخط
دفاعي متقدم عن الصين وعن محيط تايوان
الامر الاخر امريكا تقول عن الصين الواحده
ولكن هذا الوقت بالنسبه للاداره الامريكيه
كما احلل ليس الوقت المناسب
لتحويله الى واقع ملموس لماذا لان الصين
الواحده تجعل من ممر تايوان مياها اقليميه
صينيه خالصه هي الان دوليه عرض الممر مئه
ميل وبالتالي مقسم بين
جزء يتبع تايوان جزء يتبع الصين وجزء
يعتبر ممرا مائيا دوليا الان تسيطر الصين
عليه الامر الثالث التقارب الصيني الروسي
بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه واجراء مناورات
مستوره مشتركه اعتبرت الاكبر في التاريخ
شارك بها العديد من الوحدات العديد من
الطائرات في منطقه
سيبيريا وفي شرق روسيا وهناك تخطيط
لمناورات في هذا العام اذا ما هو الاجراء
البديل المحاوله الدفاع عن تايوان ضد اي
هجوم وبالتالي بدات تضغط على اليابان
وبدات اليابان لا تخضع بالمطلق ولكن بدات
تستجيب جزئيا ومن خلال كما اشرت في في لعب
الحرب التي اجراها مركز دراسات
الاستراتيجيه سي اس اي اس
بحث بصوره محدده ما هو الدور الياباني
وتبين
الولايات المتحده وفق ما نشر عن هذه الخطه
انها تتحفظ على المشاركه العسكريه ضد
الصين ولكنها تؤمن فقط الامور اللوجستيه
في هذه الخطه كيف كيف يفهم هذا الامر لواء
فايز
هذا ما قلته انه احد احد لعب الحرب احد
لعب الحرب
ركزت على الدور الخدمي والدور المساند
الاداري للقوات اليابانيه لماذا لان
اليابان بعد 1945
بنص الدستور الذي وضعته امريكا يمنع
استخدام الجيش الياباني الياباني خارج
الحدود وبالتالي ماذا هو اسم الجيش
الياباني قوات الدفاع الذاتيه اذا الان
بدا يتم اجراء تعديل طفيف على العقيد
القتاليه ورفع مستوى حجم الموازنه وحصه
الموازنه الدفاع في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي فكانت خلاصه هذا لعبه الحرب ما
تم الافصاح عنه ان يمكن يمكن
لليابان ان تقدم المساعدات الاداريه
والخدميه ولكن اشارت اشارت لعبه الحرب الى
نقطه في غايه الخطوره اكبر قواعد عسكريه
امريكيه موجود في جزيره اوكيناوا ماذا لو
تم استهدافها من قبل الصين وبالتالي هنا
تتدخل الصين اليابان عسكريا
باختصار بدقيقه
ما مستقبل ما يحدث في منطقه اسيا هذا
التوتر الحاصل هناك الى ما يمكن ان يقود
هو ان نجعل الصين مدركه بان الشياحه
تايوان هو عمل مدمر وخطير على الجميع وليس
في مصلحه الصين على الصين ان تفهم ان
الارغام
العسكري ليس الحال الدبلوماسيه مع الحكومه
التايوانيه هو الحال الولايات المتحده لا
تدعم استقلال تايوان نحن ندعم الطرفين
واجراهما
استقلال تايوان سالك قبل قليل رونغوان
لماذا يستمر بيع الاسلحه لتايوان في هذه
الاجواء
بكل بساطه لان الصين كان لديها بناء
للقدرات العسكريه الصاروخيه والبحريه
والجويه في مواجهه تايوان وقال الرئيس
الصيني انه مستعدون للاشياء في 2027 هل
تريدون ان نترك تايوان بدون ان تتمكن من
الدفاع عن نفسها
الى اين تسير الامور في اسيا في ظل كل هذا
التوتر
نحن طبعا نريد التنميه والسلام والاستقرار
ولكن كنت تريد ان تدرك الولايات المتحده
الاستمرار في تزويد الاسلحه في هذه
المنطقه
ستجعل الشعوب يعني هذه المنطقه
يجلسون على يعني متفجرات والدفعوا حذر
المنطقه الى المواجهه وتدمير شكرا لكم
جميعا من بيجين والكاتب الصحفي من نيويورك
دانس وايلذر مدير مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي السابق لشؤون الصين ومن عمان
اللواء فايز دويري الخبير والعسكري
والاستراتيجي
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على المتابعه الى هنا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]